i'm so excited to make your acquaintance
i am so excited to make yours and thank
you so much for having me i
am like such a huge fan of yours and and
always have been so thank you so much
oh my goodness i'm such a fan of yours
and i have to tell you
when i read the way you speak you're so
eloquent
and i've read a lot about how you
navigate
social media and you come from a family
that we all know but you even said i'd
rather be boring
and private than put my whole life out
there
how did you become so wise and know to
do that
well thank you that's really sweet of
you to say i i think that
you know the the value of privacy is
something that's like
been instilled in me from from an early
age and something that you know growing
up in a family like i did was always um
you know something that was uh i always
learned the importance of privacy and
and uh you know
valuing that and and and keeping things
just for yourself and so that's
something that i've carried on into my
own
career and that's really uh important to
me and you're someone who's out there
you have millions of followers
you're you know becoming this huge film
star
this you know model out there you were
literally the chanel girl and have been
for yours which is so cool because your
mom was a chanel woman
i know i know it's like the best
i i i think it's all about you know i
think
no part of it is about um not
enjoying the fun that can come from that
because obviously like you know the the
the main thing is that i'm just so
grateful to do something that i love to
do and
i really recognize the privilege in
waking up and being able to love my job
because i know that that's not true for
everybody and and so i'm really grateful
for that and
whether that's acting or or working with
chanel you know these are all things
that mean
a lot to me and so i think it's just
about um balancing that with also
wanting to
uh you know keep other things private
and and enjoy
other parts of life well that's what i
related to is because
i put myself out there and yet i'm very
protective of my kids and it can seem
sort of schizophrenic and confusing
and nobody's right and nobody's wrong
it's just these
choices and i think you have to have a
level of self-awareness
and life experience to make those
decisions and i really applaud yours
because you're right you are having fun
with that totally
totally and i and and there's so much
fun to be had you know not even
in this job but just in life you know
it's good to you know find the good and
everything and that puppy on your lap is
so cute i can't stop looking at him well
he's breaking my heart
it's it's national adopt a pet day and
we have this whole
pen of puppies and kitties and it's just
amazing how like
soothing you have a bulldog right or a
french
dog i have an english bulldog and i have
a little cat
as well and they're both um not with me
today they're they're in l.a i'm
actually going to see them
soon hopefully but you've got me extra
missing my pets today for sure well i i
well here
these are all named after bridgerton
characters have you watched bridgerton
i have not gotten to it yet but i really
it's really on my list i really need to
do
i must say miss deb run don't walk
it's so good i really really really oh
this is
broomsley bridgerton oh
um okay i love a fancy name on a pet
i also um i'm really excited
to talk to you about voyagers
i love this director i really thought
that the film limitless
stood out it's so highly respected and
he is a real visionary and this film is
no exception
so tell me if i'm getting this right
because there are
basically people bred and born to
not be on earth and to
live in a different atmosphere and be
sort of
given a lifestyle that will make them
act a certain way but human nature
is human nature
yes that feels that feels quite accurate
basically
they have been born and bred for this
mission they've bred these
kids and then when we meet them again
they're like 16 17 and they basically
discover that they've been taking
the blue which is this kind of sedative
basically that's made
to make sure that they don't that their
hormones aren't kind of like running
wild and and that they basically stay on
track and that they say these kind of
little
uh work machines for the mission and
then you know
once that uh fact is discovered
and uh you know people stop taking it
and stuff things kind of um
all chaos kind of ensues after that i
just love this and you are so compelling
and so beautiful and so cool and i can't
wait to see you at the forefront of this
really interesting movie
thank you so much well that's so sweet
and same to you you are such a
sunny positive wonderful energy and it
was so lovely to meet you and speak to
you and see your face it was so lovely
to meet you
lily rose depp voyagers is in theaters
today
and it's so engaging go watch it think
feel and get raucous